si la classe politique se montre
critique face à l'avant projet de loi
anti copie qui sera examinée le 21
juillet à l'assemblée nationale
la rue dénonce également ces nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires nouvel appel à
la mobilisation demain partout en france
après des manifestations mercredi qui
ont réuni dix neuf mille personnes sur
l'ensemble de l'hexagone
écoutez à ce sujet laurent jacobellis
porte parole du rassemblement national
cette facture elle est voulue elle est
organisée elle est souhaitée par le
président de la république que des
milliers ou des millions de français
veulent se faire vacciner c'est je crois
une bonne nouvelle pour la lutte contre
la pandémie mais cela doit se faire sur
la base de la liberté individuelle du
libre consentement
or le pass sanitaire j'aimerais que l'on
s'en rende compte c'est un recul sans
précédent de nos libertés ça veut dire
que chaque français va surveiller
d'autres français que chaque français
devra a dénoncé d'autres français
notamment à l'entrée des restaurants
ça veut dire que deux français n'auront
pas les mêmes droits
selon qu'ils sont vaccinés ou pas
vaccinés on n'a jamais vu ça on n'a
jamais vu ça pour un virus en plus qui
aujourd'hui peut être relativement bien
contrôler en fait le gouvernement fait
porter le poids très lourd de son échec
dans la lutte contre la pandémie sur les
françaises c'est une solution feignante
feignante en termes de créativité et
feignante en termes de respect des
libertés